on the televised mental institution of
nbc uh they are also acknowledging that
there's a big problem uh for the
democrats when it comes to minorities
because the democrats have basically
owned minorities and what happens when
minorities start figuring out what's
what what do you have to do
you've got to scare the hell out of them
and it is in campaigns we have these
ideas of okay to that that third that
dao is talking about they gotta
understand they have skin in the game
and right now they don't really believe
they have skin in the game this is the
point that down's making
campaigns we gotta we gotta give them a
reason to feel they have skin in the
game that this is important to them that
losing democracy is important to them
and whether it be not whether or not it
be telling women that you know what
women you think you're losing your
rights now
what
what do you think's going to happen if
we if we don't have democracy you know
what african-americans particularly
african-american men who are showing the
lowest motivation to turn out in this
midterm you think things are tough for
you right now
where do you think you're going to
stand in a country like in america where
there's where there's no democracy where
they have absolutely no interest or
at all and and respecting you respecting
your respecting your rights we've got to
get
let these people understand that they've
got skin in this game and they've got
and they got we got to scare the hell
out of them because quite frankly nicole
they should be afraid that we're going
to lose our democracy
it's a fantasy land it's genuinely a
fantasy land there are people that watch
msnbc and it's it's not that many people
anymore right it's not that many people
anymore but there's a set of people that
are influential in the political world
that watch that that respond to that and
you're watching that thinking that what
are you saying the republicans are
coming for your rights the republicans
are coming for black people and all of
those things as you guys know we've
talked about it a million times uh black
and latino unemployment was at an
all-time low
uh when donald trump was president when
the congressional black caucus sat there
when he said it remember he said it at
the state of the union black and latino
unemployment at all time
we don't like you orange man we hate you
more than we like black and latino
people latinos are leaving the democrat
party in droves they are leaving leave
and leaving and even cnn is talking
about it there are differences in what's
going on with the latino vote if you
look at texas florida and arizona these
are three districts that are a little
bit let's call them emblematic of what
we're talking about florida 27 this is
the miami-dade area it went from being
clinton by 19 in 2016 to biden by just
three in 2020 texas 15 that is on the
mexico border uh clinton 16 to biden
plus two arizona this is the tucson area
so arizona is a place that some
democrats say
think that helped biden win that state
it went from clinton 29 to biden 27. so
not a huge shift but still
in texas and in florida there are big
erosions happening big erosion's
happening
you see how she didn't want to say the
last part she kind of paused she was
kind of choking on her words
it's happening but still it's happening
everyone gets why this is happening
there's many reasons why it's happening
first off
generally speaking latino communities
whether they are mexican or honduran or
wherever they might be
from they lean in their in their
cultural
norms they lean a little more
conservative the democrats have done a
great job they've particularly done this
with the black community you know my
feelings on the word community that
they've confused people into thinking
that big government means good things
that if we give you things that is good
but the ethics the cultural values of
these communities tend to be a little
more conservative then you take what's
going on in texas with these open
borders and people
that are just pouring through our
borders well if you were a new immigrant
to america a legal immigrant and you did
it fairly right or it was your father or
mother or grandparents that did it
fairly and you lived in one of these
border communities and you're working
hard and doing the american dream doing
what you probably are doing right now or
what your parents or grandparents your
great-grandparents did before you and
you're working hard to get more so that
your kids will have more and all of that
stuff and then you see in your border
town somewhere in texas you see all
these people just pouring in and the
government's going to give them money
and the government's going to give them
phones and other benefits and all of
those things you might be annoyed and
then you might be able to connect that
to the policies of uh the biden
administration and then you might even
be able to remember back to that orange
man who was talking about building a
wall and it wasn't a racist wall it was
a wall that just said hey we've got a
border and a border if you want to
actualize it it would be a physical
thing known as a wall and we can all
talk about whether a wall makes the most
sense or electronic surveillance or some
part of a wall and some part of
electronic surveillance or boats or
alligators or whatever it might be but
the point is when you take the
immigration stuff
that is huge you take some of the
cultural norms boys or girls and all of
that stuff that doesn't really fly with
these people and then you take the
ridiculous
language of the woke the la tinx
t l-a-t-i-e n x the le tinx a word that
no latino person has ever said it is
wildly offensive most of the words in
spanish are gendered right that's how it
works that's how it works and they have
completely pushed all this nonsense on
these people it's all coming from elite
white liberals that's how it comes from
the woke and they're pushing it on these
people